repletas y una larga lista de espera
marcan el panorama de los hospitales en
Shanghai a medida que los casos de
contagios aumentan en China desde que el
gobierno acabó con su política de cero
covid un panorama por el que la OMS ha
demandado al país asiático que publique
sus datos sobre el crecimiento de las
infecciones
no prestó mucha atención a los datos
para definitivamente se están retrasando
y habrá algunos que no se reportarán
definitivamente no hay forma de evitar
esto
la falta de cifras veraces y el temor de
una nueva oleada ha llevado a muchos
países occidentales a implementar
medidas para Los viajeros provenientes
de China unas restricciones que han sido
condenadas por el país asiático por
supuestamente responder a motivos
políticos
esto no tiene base científica de algunas
prácticas son inaceptables nos oponemos
firmemente a todos los intentos de
manipular las medidas de prevención de
epidemias para lograr objetivos
políticos tomaremos contra medidas
basadas en el principio de reciprocidad
unas declaraciones que se dan en el
marco del anuncio de la Unión Europea
del ofrecimiento de vacunas al gigante
asiático la comisaria kiriakide se ha
acercado a sus homólogos chinos para
ofrecerles solidaridad y apoyo de la
Unión Europea y esto incluye experiencia
en salud pública así como a través de
vacunas adaptadas por variantes de la
Unión Europea una propuesta que aún no
ha sido aceptada por china que ha estado
inoculando su población con sus propias
vacunas unas que usan la tecnología del
virus inactivado y no aquella del ARN
mensajero utilizada en buena parte de
occidente que ha demostrado una alta
eficacia